[Music]
you're gloria steinem
i am
[Music]
travel is the best education it's the
only education really
i just returned from two years in india
the stories i saw and heard are amazing
i'm going to try you out on a fashion
assignment if you want me to laugh
they give a pay cuts if you don't smile
you don't fit into your costume or if we
don't do the bunny dip while serving
i've been working nine hours with no
break maybe we ought to join a union
how about next time going undercover in
the porno business
those are too big they hide your
beautiful face they're perfect
those women and bunny outfits are going
to thank you one day
i have a fear of public speaking what
dorothy and i have to say is too
important
not to say it this is the year of
women's liberation
a simple right to reproductive freedom
it's basic
we're here to make revolution not just
dinner we gotta stop sucking and begin
to buy it
you're working from within the movement
now change comes from within
every minute is a chance to change the
world
what are you lesbians what are you the
alternative
i thought i would talk about why harvard
law school needs women
more than women need it how dare you
this is going to be a disaster
stop the bus you're broken down that
tire are we there yet
this isn't the first time you've had
knives thrown edges
why didn't i object get out and slam the
door you will lots of times
speaking your mind will get you in deep
trouble the truth will set you free
but first we'll piss you off
[Music]
the road is messy and the way the real
life is messy
it leads us out of denial and into
reality
it leads us on our heads
and into our hearts we'll rise
[Music]